here's what would happen if the
yellowstone volcano erupted tomorrow
if you live in north america there would
be virtually nothing you could do to
prepare yellowstone's magma would be
shot up into the sky becoming airborne
ash particles and it won't just be any
type of ash
these would be scorching tiny particles
of jagged rock
tens of millions of people within a 1
000 kilometer radius of the eruption
would die
if you breathed the ash it would form a
cement-like mixture in your lungs
causing you to suffocate
buildings would collapse as just 30
centimeters of ash is enough to cave
roofs in
experts say that even the east coast of
the united states would be covered in
one centimeter of ash which would be
incredibly dangerous to our human lungs
even some parts of europe would see ash
also ash lingering in the air would
block out the sun resulting in
significant weather changes and would
affect our crops water supply and
virtually everything else in the western
part of the world
luckily something like this will
probably never happen
at least not in our lifetime so